a quick one here you guys ever watched
prison break it was a huge show for a
while
yes i didn't watch it but i know exactly
what it is so it's supposed to come back
for i think a sixth season or something
like that
but then finally the main star wentworth
miller who happens to be gay
he decided just last minute not to do it
because he doesn't want to continue to
play straight characters
geez when i'm thinking about this i'm
like to limit his [ __ ]
scope of roles i know if you're only gay
dudes
and this whole production you know
co-stars and all that stuff i guess
they're not going to do it either then
oh they'll replace him i didn't i didn't
know well if there's another guy dominic
purcell you know dominic purcell
they'll replace him with like this he
could be a gay dude on the show
i don't know i know it's acting yeah i
don't know yeah he could he could i mean
interesting because that's the whole
point of your job you're an actor you're
supposed to be
you're pretending that yeah you're
straight you're playing pretend
professionally exactly
can you imagine if a straight guy went i
i don't want to play any gay roles
i will only play straight roles you'd be
[ __ ] yeah
so yeah i think you still have some kind
of thing and there's just an art to
acting to be able to do that to take
yourself outside of
yeah yeah that's the whole thing it's
called acting dude
act like you're straight homeboy and
this guy who is his co-star
i guess he supports him too even though
he's going to be losing out on a big i'm
sure a huge payday for
for continuing just [ __ ] replace them
i don't get the problem
those are the numbers a million guys
with shaved heads you can have they were
the two main stars
yeah i think it's one of those shows
with a cult following that it's going to
be
hard for you to get someone to replace
him because he's kind of the face
there's if there's enough money in it
and there's enough following yeah trust
me that we'll replace them i mean
yeah hollywood got that money oh that's
true it's the same thing with like
uh johnny depp in that uh fantastic
beasts
yeah yeah but that's a little different
he wasn't like that big
he isn't like what you think of when you
think of harry potter
like even fantastic beasts isn't as succ
anywhere near successful as the harry
potter series correct when you think
harry potter it's like
replacing daniel radcliffe like you
can't really do that well i can try it
i bet you could really yeah i don't
think harry potter
i think you guys forget i mean don't get
me wrong like i think hollywood would
try but i don't think there's
gonna be enough money it's gonna move
the circus moves on there's not one
person that powerful enough where
they're just gonna
shut down entire production there's no
way i hope not i had a call
trust me they won't figure it out they
can't replace nick cannon for walling
out
yeah because they still buy they tried
they tried yeah but his boys turned it
down but they were gonna do it they were
gonna do it but his boys were like no
we're not gonna do show and i love it
it's loyalty
yeah loyalty loyalty that's what they're
doing here too though
his cast mates are agreeing with them so
they don't want to join on either well i
i didn't say that yeah wait till this
quarantine pandemic hits a little long
and the paychecks aren't coming in like
maybe we should do something i'm still
paying payments on my rolex so i hope
i'll be good for them but i would assume
you know it's on fox right
i think it's still fire box has some
hits
right what brock's turning 24 survivor
american idol yes american biggest they
have lost
simpsons simpsons oh american dad
was that on fox well fox had family guy
simpson
oh they have family members cleveland
yeah yeah i think that was their slogan
right
fox got the kids i'm almost positive
that was it
i don't think so it might be fx has the
hit yeah
fa by the way yeah it might be fast fx
coming up snowfall
dave and lincoln i feel like fx has
argo fargo oh yeah american uh horror
story
horror story shout out to duron yeah
they did pose
oh damn this is a really popular one i
heard that show was good that that green
looking one
love what we do in the shadows wins a
bunch of awards right yeah
our damn i don't [ __ ] with archer but
they're
sons of animals they had watched it
right the americans that was a good one
bought these like yeah people loved the
americans justified was big
yeah so foxy
american crime story was fantastic
mm-hmm the league was huge
baskets were my guy from hangover oh
there's louie
yeah yeah dude they had the shield for
six years
so a lot of good shows a lot of
guardianship joey anderson
but yeah they coming up but fox also had
american idol let's not forget about
that
mm-hmm kind of like launched that was
they like leap
frog what took them all simpsons doug
yeah this was amazing
children was all on fox oh it was
holding it simpson's been around for
30 years but who who had i think
american idol just had their that was
their biggest show at one point
and it was for years so that's why i
think that was big but it would be
simple
for a great man married with children
yeah they had big shows oh nbc had
scrubs
right yeah general hospital
okay apologize i used to stay in my
grandma she's half soap so
oh they got brooklyn nine-nine yeah i
don't [ __ ] with any of these
what blind spot crazy anything on
mainstream to you like
i don't [ __ ] with that i like jimmy
fallon kelly clarkson so it's kind of
does anyone watch titan games is that
doing well it's on netflix now
okay oh uh which isn't bad no
oh shout out to trust me he didn't go
there shades of blue with uh
uh jennifer lopez
it's been a long day it's been a long
i would just stop shouting out celebrity
names yeah he said it so confidently
i did i did all right brendan this is
from douglas goudenow jr
uh your guy rip i guess his real life
house is a ranch
here in santa monica this is a real it's
in santa barbara it's beautiful
we're near santa monica near santa
monica there's ranches out here
yeah i uh bike past them all the time so
they sell them for four point two
five million and where socal ranch i'll
look at the exact area
wow agora hills where's very close to me
yeah oh dope why is he selling it
upgrading it's probably moving in but
it's an actual ranch over here yeah
that looks great oh that's that looks so
you know where agora hills is at so it
goes
uh so it goes woodland hills calabasas
or gora hills
got it thousand oaks oh so yeah in the
same area okay yeah
all right dopey it's beautiful out there
though i can tell by the picture yeah
i'm trying to get out more that way i
want to get away from the crazy okay
maybe not that close to santa monica
calabasas area
yeah yep what's in the santa monica
mountains that's that's true in santa
monica
um coyotes are how about that when i get
off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song